[Música]
boa tarde é se eu perguntasse pra vocês
que é na infância que a gente é capaz de
descobrir que essa que um adulto será
depois que crescesse acreditar em mim e
se eu fosse um pouquinho mais ousada de
6 que são os brinquedos que são os
modeladores de todas as habilidades
competências interesses e aptidões
paixões frutos que iriam construir essa
criança desenvolver uma das suas maiores
habilidades que seria o
intraempreendedorismo secretaria em mim
eu também não
quando criança eu tive três brinquedos
um par de sapatos velhos do meu irmão
uma saboneteira de banho e o mais
enigmático de todos os brinquedos
o velocity durante a minha graduação
como terapeuta ocupacional e depois como
mestranda em antropologia social a
bicicleta sempre esteve presente foram
várias e várias vezes que eu fui pra
federal é pedalando pra pra fazer as
aulas mas o mais incrível eo mais
curioso da minha relação com a bicicleta
aconteceu que em 2008 eu passei um dos
concursos mais disputados do brasil
naquela época era bem visto talvez não
tanto agora e foi ouvindo áudios de
lições de direito administrativo
constitucional e pedalando que eu
consegui passar nesse concurso público
ou seja a bicicleta é uma ferramenta que
abre a percepção abre o olhar abre a
possibilidade de concentração de foco de
visualização de futuro aos 35 anos de
idade eu tinha passado no concurso
público eu tinha terminado meu cunha
minha defesa de mestrado que encontrar
um grande amor da minha vida
estava tudo pronto para ter uma vida
quase que completa aos 35 anos
quando no dia 14 de setembro de 2009
uma caminhonete colidiu com a minha vida
e nesse dia todos os ossos a minha perna
esquerda eles foram quebrados e teve
fratura exposta do fêmur
o natural que é o deslocamento né do do
quadril à atibaia a fíbula e o mais
incrível de tudo foi o joelho né porque
quebrou é justamente o platô tibial e
nesse dia foi assim muito
assim é impressionante porque as pessoas
sempre diziam pra mim que existe uma luz
no final do túnel
só que no meu caso quando houve essa
essa colisão e meu corpo e ele ficou
flutuando no ar por segundos que
pareciam eternidade até ele cair ao chão
e fazer um barulho muito forte parecia
que era uma placa de chumbo caindo 1
turno se abriu eu não vi pede que os
fiéis e muito menos cantou a música do
ghost mas foi ali que eu percebi o outro
lado da vida e talvez não tive mais tive
uma experiência de quase morte mas eu
lembro como se fosse hoje o grande amor
da minha vida
no começo do túnel gritava sá voltas a
volta e eu voltei eu voltei pra me
tornar a primeira para ciclista wc 2 do
brasil
ou seja eu pedalo com o movimento da
minha perna direita
tudo começou com uma brincadeira de uma
forma descompromissada
sem saber que ao longo dos treinamentos
que eu fosse o treinador no alto
rendimento pelo meu técnico fernando
firmino eu iria me tornar tricampeão da
copa brasil para ciclismo
eu estive em vários estados em várias
cidades brasília curitiba interior do
estado de são paulo
surdo do país rio de janeiro
nessa época até 2015
eu tinha como com alicerce de vida uma
única palavra empatia
eu tinha que me colocar no lugar do
outro para tentar superar bullen
preconceitos
a questão do próprio do machismo ea
questão do que era se tornar uma pessoa
com deficiência aos 35 anos de idade
tudo caminhava muito bem mas eu sentia
que algo poderia ser um pouco além
afinal de contas a cena colocou isso né
quando a gente conhece o limite existe a
possibilidade da gente um pouquinho mais
e foi quando em 2015
apareceu a eva esta cachorrinha
pequenininha madrinha que está do lado
de cá
fruto de uma bandoneon no futuro de maus
tratos mas detentora de uma capacidade
de amor que eu nunca vi em toda a minha
vida foi a ela que eu dedico toda a
minha história de vida em 2015 essa
vitória me apresentou a ciência
nessa outra foto que ela tá foi a nossa
última foto quando eu assumi o concurso
público nós mudamos pra bahia ela é do
sul da bahia de uma cidade que chama
ilhéus e aí por meio de eva vitória de
2015 eu deixei de comer produtos de
origem animal e nos lançamos para os
maiores desafios em nossas vidas visando
à convocação das paraolimpíadas rio 2016
foi então que nós fizemos em itabuna é
que distante 200 quilômetros depois nós
fizemos os 300 quilômetros
é essa essa e se bebeu não completei
porque eu tive seis furos de pneu
ficaram faltando 48 quilômetros 15 horas
de vantagem
fizemos hood brasil haider inclusive a
prova é amanhã
isso foi em 2000 e 2016
tudo visando à convocação das para as
olimpíadas
essa prova é muito interessante ela tem
só 70 quilômetros
só que ela acumula de ascensão de
elevação quase 1.700 metros
nós tínhamos apenas quatro horas para
cumprir
a prova e nós conseguimos gravar em três
horas e 58 minutos e 12 segundos
na mesma semana uma semana depois eu fiz
as 12 horas de bh comendo banana da
terra e tomando água de coco eu
conseguir pedalar 11 horas e 45 perdão
11 horas e 15 minutos
a gente trabalhou a fronteira 270
quilômetros e finalmente a convocação
para as paraolimpíadas não aconteceu
aconteceu o convite para reconhecer o
percurso das para as olimpíadas foi além
dos meus sonhos foi além daquilo que eu
poderia a acreditar como a única
representante do brasil na categoria wc
esta era a iaa a seleção da época
nós fomos reconhecer o percurso e não
conseguiam conseguir subir a serra de
grumari com o movimento de uma única
perna aqui foi quando concluiu o evento
teste
e aí chega em 2016 e eu reunisse baú
esse baú de memórias
esse baú de afetos esse baú de
conquistas
esse barulho de simbologias esse baú de
aprendizado de 2016 para 2018 eu tive
uma transição muito séria também estava
um pouco desanimada porque eu tava só
trabalha na questão da empatia com o
outro mas foi quando mais uma vez dois
alicerces entraram na minha vida a
resiliência eo altruísmo
foi quando mais uma vez por meio de eva
inspiração dela de tudo o que ela vem
mostrando o dia a dia
nós voltamos com força esta foto onde eu
finalizo o rostinho dela ali aponta o
dedo era um recado pra mim mesmo presta
atenção você tem um tempo muito curto
para realizar os seus sonhos
então eu encontro o significado de
pedalar que era quase impossível
abandonar aquele emprego aquela aquele
belo sítio da infância
nós lançamos novamente em 2017 o desafio
de destrava o oedt aí dá pra
são carlos aparecida a primeira a
primeiro dia foram 230 quilômetros e o
segundo dia foram 180 quilômetros a
amanhã vocês terem idéia acontece o bike
cirs né que é acontece em interlagos é o
ano passado eu fiz esse desafio é
visando mais uma vez a a convocação para
representar o nosso país
esse evento foi muito mágico porque além
de estar pedalando a naquela pessoa que
eu tenho a maior inspiração e acordava
como todos vocês todas as manhãs não
perdia nenhuma corrida que é airton sena
eu tinha o sonho de subir o swu cena e
nós subimos meu músculo fez literalmente
um sna na perna mas a gente fez essa
homenagem eu não sei se eu chorava
quando eu escutava a música de cena ou
se chorava de dor em 2018 eo cravo bi
campeonato brasileiro e esse gesto
descerrar o punho nunca foi um gesto de
tirar vantagem de mostrar que eu sou a
melhor o que eu posso ser
era um gesto do quanto vale a pena você
acreditar e viver seus sonhos para 2019
agora é existe esta prova que é a prova
mais tradicional do calendário da elite
feminina no brasil é são as melhores
ciclistas do do brasil que pedalam todas
elas é são normais com a expressão da
palavra ou seja todas elas pedalam com o
movimento das duas pernas
é um desafio que é uma prova que é
composta de três dias e quatro etapas e
e eu como propósito maior esteve
presente com elas e finalmente de uma
forma de me reinventar novamente né
é de dentro de um propósito maior que um
evento avulso que eu vou apresentar para
vocês em abril eu me lancei para o
ciclismo de pista no velódromo né
e mais uma vez pelas mulheres por eva eu
me sinto muito a grata de ter sido a
primeira mulher wc 2
a pedalada no velódromo esta prova a
onde eu onde eu fui conseguiu a ser
campeã é cravou a minha primeira
experiência a história da compra desta
bicicleta foi muito engraçado e muito
rápida muito efervescente
eu comprei em dezembro ela chegou em
fevereiro em abril pela primeira vez eu
pedalei no velódromo e consegui a ter um
bom resultado bom finalmente não estamos
agora no ranking do brasil né eu sou a
brasileira o maior ranking e na minha
categoria essas duas medalhas foram
obtidas agora esse ano e nós temos agora
pela frente um mês e meio uma provável
convocação pralimão jogos parapan
parapan né que vão acontecer e para o
ano que vem nós temos antoun ok 2020 e
na virada de 2020 para 2021
independentes mais uma vez esses eventos
não não derem certo eu não ser convocada
o brasil terá o primeiro registro wc 2
do brasil e do mundo onde eu espero
registrar a marca do da maior quantidade
de quilômetros pedalados em uma única
perna e por fim se tudo isso não dê
certo a única coisa que eu tenho pra
dizer pra vocês é que o amor triunfará
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]